[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
imaginez un salon par la fenêtre un
soleil radieux de début d'après midi au
fond de la pièce
les lueurs d'une télévision et
étrangement aucun bruit à un mètre de la
télé une petite fille elle a mis la télé
sur pause elle dessine ses héros de
dessins animés préférés
cette petite fille c'est moi je disais
que je serai dessinatrice on a tous des
rêves d'enfants je ne sais pas quelles
étaient les vôtres qu'elles sont encore
des vôtres et puis un jour je me
retrouve à travailler huit heures par
jour devant un ordinateur
ma vie n'a aucun sens pire j'ai
l'impression que je suis un virus un
virus qui participent à détruire la
planète
un virus qui ne devrait pas exister
qui ici a déjà entendu parler de
permaculture ah ouais quand même
alors vous pensez que la permaculture
c'est une façon de cultiver vous avez
raison c'est une façon de cultiver la
terre mais aussi de cultiver l'esprit
c'est aussi une philosophie une
philosophie née de l'observation de la
nature
une philosophie qui à redonner du sens à
ma vie une philosophie où chaque chose à
sa place et sa fonction comme les
cellules d'un corps une philosophie où
la concurrence n'existe pas car chacun
d'entre nous à quelque chose d'unique et
de précieux à apporter au monde
est ce que vous êtes venu apporter c'est
simplement faire ce qu'il ya dix ans
pour vous c'est que vous aimez tellement
peur que vous en perdez toute notion du
trou comment imaginez-vous ce monde là
moi ce qui me fait perdre toute notion
du temps c'est créer et puis aussi les
arts martiaux la philosophie explorer
les mystères de l'univers inventé un
monde de demain qui me ferait envie à
l'aise bon alors maintenant comment est
ce que je fais pour en faire un métier
mais un jour pendant un stage de
méditation j'ai eu une révélation
le maître nous explique ce qui se passe
quand on est en chaque partie du corps
quand il arrive à la langue hindi quand
vous détendez votre langue vous détendez
les cordes vocales
et cela détend la zone du cerveau qui se
charge du langage et vous avez moins de
penser hu
[Musique]
là je me dis et mais ce gars là il est
en train de m'apprendre comment je
fonctionne
mais pourquoi on m'a pas appris ça quand
j'étais petit je veux dire si ça existe
pourquoi on ne va pas donner le mode
d'emploi avec quoi je découvre ébahi et
l'étendue de mon ignorance et ce qui me
fait passer à l'action
c'est une petite question sur laquelle
je tombe un jour si vous mourriez dans
deux mois qu'est ce que vous aimeriez
l'essayer au monde
je décide de partager le mode d'emploi
que j'ai commencé à découvrir si de
telles connaissances existe alors tout
le monde a le droit d'y avoir accès et
si j'ai au moins contribué à faire ça
alors ma vie n'aura pas été complètement
inutile du coup ben je fais des bandes
dessinées bah oui on fait avec ses
compétences font et je les publie sur
mon blog
quand j'ai dit said c'est la fête
il ya des gens qui lisent les vedettes
c'est trop cool et puis un jour je
décide de me mettre à mon compte
[Musique]
cette fois c'est du sérieux
c'en est fini de tourner autour du pot
je me donne un an pour développer des
projets et en vivres pièces et à matin
le réveil sonne hélas rien
plus d'énergie ont plus envie
je ne ressens plus rien devant un tel
paysage intérieur
ah ouais quand même que dirait quelqu'un
qui pratique la permaculture mon
diagnostic surexploitation des sols oui
c'est possible je travaillais 13 heures
par jour j'ai été acharnée mais je
voulais tellement y arriver avec juste
réussi à me faire un burn-out tout seul
bon que ferait un père m'a culteurs
devant ce paysage désertique
simplement il nourrir est la terre je
comprends qu'il s'agit de ma portée de
nouveau des petits moments de plaisir et
de joie
petit à petit me reconnecter à la vie je
fais la liste des choses que j'adore et
en fait il faut quand même plusieurs
mois rien que pour m'autoriser à faire
de nouveau des choses par plaisir bon et
puis j'observe
j'observe l'évolution à je commence à
aller mieux je ressens de nouveau
quelque chose je ressens des
frustrations je me sens inutile
j'ai l'impression que j'arrêtais bailly
que je le meilleur effet que des
mauvaises herbes
en même temps si on réfléchit un peu
c'est normal phoenix a qui poussent
puisqu'en fait j'ai rien planter nouveau
mais alors quoi planter de nouveaux
logiquement il faudrait carrément que je
joue au paysagiste
comme ça je saurai quoi planter et ou
qu'est ce que vous en pensez
ok j'imagine mon jardin ma vie idéale hu
maintenant j'ai un plan quelle est la
prochaine étape à votre avis et bien
avant même de planter de nouvelles
graines il s'agit de défricher et en
faisant ce travail de défrichage je
découvre des choses extraordinaires
je me découvre que pour se libérer d'un
passé qui se répète
il existe des méthodes simples et
efficaces
je découvre que mes émotions
les interactions entre mon corps et mon
esprit tout ça à une logique un mode de
fonctionnement et tout ça peut
s'apprendre mais alors si ça peut
s'apprendre pourquoi on m'a pas appris
ça à l'école bon sens mais découverte
s'accélère je recommence à publier sur
mon blog janvier 2015
un miracle une de mes bd se partagent à
plus de 10000 ait une maison d'édition
le contact et me propose d'éditer mes
histoires je n'avais jamais osé
contacter de maisons d'édition avant
c'est trop c'est trop cool ça bouge ça
pousse j'ai défriché ce qui me retenait
à mon passé j'ai planté de nouvelles
pensées de nouveaux comportements et
timidement ma vie commence à ressembler
à ce que j'ai design et mon jardin prend
vie je voyage je vais à des conférences
je rencontre des gens passionnants on
m'a même invité à dessiner en direct une
traque
je tremble mais je me lance je continue
à reconstituer le mode d'emploi de
l'humain d'électeurs m'encourage 2 ou 3
me font même
ton à quelqu'un qui m'a donné 10 euros
il ya quelqu'un qui croit ce que j'ai
bon allez moi aussi je crois en moi je
me sens vivante tout est possible bon en
même temps tout est possible je ne vous
cache pas que c'est pas facile tout le
temps il ya toujours des moments de
doute de remise en question des
problèmes mais en permaculture on dit
qu'il n'ya jamais de problème seulement
des ressources qui n'ont pas encore
exploité exploiter et ça me rappelle
toujours l'histoire des limaces des
canards vous voulez l'entendre yeahs
alors imaginez que vous ayez dans votre
potager des limaces en fait vous n'avez
pas de problème de limaces vous n'avait
juste pas encore introduit les canards
qui vont bouffer les limaces canard qui
vaut au site cruauté partout sur votre
terrain et enrichir le sol de cette
façon vous aurez transformer vos libasse
en plus de richesses bon alors
concrètement dans ma vie à moi les
limaces et les canards vous voulez
savoir ce que ça donne et bien
l'histoire la plus frappante qui me
vient c'est quand j'ai eu un conflit
avec un collègue il me dit je ne sais
pas si tu t'en rends compte
mais tes mots sont super violent jolie
massin et bien le canard que ça m'a
permis d'introduire dans ma vie c'est la
communication non violente et tout mais
leurs relations sont devenues mille fois
plus riche
mille fois plus savoureuse et c'est même
une source d'inspiration pour les
histoires que j'écris
en fait comme j'ai plein de problèmes
ben j'ai plein d'occasions de m'enrichir
du coup je l'apprends l'autohypnose la
communication non-violente ça je voulais
des zi la programmation
neurolinguistique plusieurs méthodes de
libération émotionnelle des thérapies
quantique du kung fu du tai-chi du
chicon du feng shui et j'en passe qu'est
ce que vous en pensez
ça donnerait presque envie d'avoir des
problèmes
alors aujourd'hui j'ai sorti trois
bandes dessinées sur le thème du
développement personnel de l'intuition
et des émotions certain que j'écris
entièrement et d'autres que je coécris
mon potager prendre de plus en plus
forme
pièce je co créée avec des gens généreux
drôle et avec qui on partage des valeurs
et le plus qui font ces les messages que
je reçois de mes lecteurs il y a des
thérapeutes qui utilisent mes bandes
dessinées avec leurs patients il y à des
instituteurs qui lisent mes bd avec
leurs élèves quand ils font des cours
sur les émotions
oui ça existe maintenant il y amène une
maman qui m'a raconté que sa fille était
très nerveuse et avaient du mal à
s'endormir et que depuis qu'elle a lu ma
dernière bd sur les émotions et bien
aller beaucoup plus sereine et s'endort
très rapidement ouah vous imaginez le
mode d'emploi que j'aurais tellement
aimé avoir étant petit
maintenant des enfants et on taxait je
me sens en haïti à ma place
est ce que est ce que je trouve le plus
formidable en tête c'est que je fais
juste ce qui me fait triper le plus au
monde
aller à la découverte du mode d'emploi
du mans et le partager un quoi si
j'arrive à en vivre
ah oui on me la posent souvent celle là
eh bien oui
en fait je comprends sa question parce
que moi aussi comme beaucoup de gens je
pensais qu'il n'était pas possible de
vivre de sa passion
en fait janvier ce qui arrivé et je me
sentais tellement nu de porc va être
capable je tournais en rond dans ma zone
de confort trop flipper pour en sortir
et puis en reconstituant mon mode
d'emploi j'ai découvert que la largeur
de ma zone de confort est égale à la
largeur de ma pensée et que donc pour
élargir sa zone de confort
eh bien il s'agit de way d'élargir sa
pensée son champ des possibles et ça
simplement ça peut commencer par une
nouvelle idée alors j'ai envie de vous
partager cette idée ici c'est justement
parce que l'on fait ce qui nous
passionne que l'argent vient parce que
c'est comme ça que ça se passe dans le
monde dans la nature une cellule du
corps elle a juste être à sa place a
donné qu' elle est ce qu'elle sait faire
et en échange elle reçoit tout ce dont
elle a besoin pour vivre
merci
[Applaudissements]